bonjour à tous la plupart des missiles
russes ont été neutralisés mais pas
suffisamment pour éviter de nouvelles
victimes les Ukrainiens annoncent un
premier bilan de 11 morts ce jeudi les
rues sont frappé massivement l'ensemble
du territoire Emmanuel Chaze bonjour on
vous retrouve en direct de Kiev quels
sont les dernières informations dont
vous disposez
oui
ce chiffre de
rimes c'est le résultat de cette attaque
ce matin 55 missiles lancés à travers
tout le territoire
ukrainien certains missiles étaient
destinés à la capitale Kiev l'un d'entre
eux est tombé sur sur un immeuble
résidentiel résultat un mort de blessés
qui ont été hospitalisés à zaporigia
trois personnes sont également décédées
au total 11 morts 11 personnes blessées
dans ce qui est malheureusement ici
devenu finalement assez habituel toutes
les deux ou trois semaines il y a une
attaque de grande ampleur avec des
douzaines de des dizaines de missiles ou
encore de drone des drones comme la nuit
passée 24 drones chahead qui ont été des
drogues kamikazes donc qui ont été
lancés encore une fois à travers tout le
territoire ukrainien par les forces
russes 15 de ces drones ont été abattus
au dessus de la capitale Kiev pour les
habitants ici ça ça veut dire ça se
traduit en heure chaque nuit chaque jour
passé à tenter de se protéger de ces de
ces explosions de ces bombes la nuit
dernière on a passé 4 heures dans un
dans un bunker aujourd'hui encore ce
matin après seulement quelques heures et
cette alerte et c'est drone tomber sur
sur la ville on a encore passé plus de 4
heures
enfermé comme tout toutes les personnes
qui craignent pour leur vie comme je le
disais c'est malheureusement devenu
habituel ici depuis le 24 février
dernier et l'agression russe contre le
crâne merci beaucoup Emmanuel chaise
pour ces éléments effectivement br